[Musik]
durch diese tür gingen millionen raver
und djs aus aller welt darunter stars
wie der deutsche paul van dyk also
zunächst mal kann man denn so eine art
vorraum verstandene bat aber auch der
die idee am anfang dann war so ein
gitter und da stand dann einfach die
anlage drin und er wurde dann auch
entsprechend gefeiert
wenn man dadurch ging durch den raum und
hat auch diese stahlgitter dieses
schließfächer diese gewaltige türen
das war beeindruckt reise in die 90er
jahre
der club tresor macht berlin damals zu
internationalen techno hochburg und die
deutsche hauptstadt als party metropole
weltbekannt bis zu seiner schließung
2005 legen hier alle damals relevanten
djs auf wie jeff mills aus detroit
[Musik]
und heute weltbekannte stars wie der
deutsche paul van dyk starten im tresor
ihre karriere
es war halt meine allererste schon das
erste mal dass ich vor leuten gespielt
habe insofern ich war halt zu hause habe
den buzzer ausgedreht alles immer schön
leise und da stand dann dieses große
große das rohrsystem das heißt jetzt das
erste mal sachen in meiner musik gehört
die vorher gar nicht da waren und das
hat bei mir und letztendlich auch
ausgelöst werden wie ok das ist es das
möchte ich machen
heute ist die tresortür das erste objekt
einer großen berlin ausstellung die im
jahr 2020 öffnen soll
[Musik]
im fast fertigen nachbau des
historischen berliner schlosses dem
humboldtforum
hier wird im kommenden jahr unter
anderem eine ausstellung über berlin im
austausch mit der welt gezeigt kurator
paul spies hat die tür ins museum geholt
das ding ist symbol für 100 jahre berlin
geschichte den anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts schützt die tür den tresor
des kaufhauses wertheim damals das
größte und prächtigste kaufhaus europas
die jüdischen besitzer werden später von
den nationalsozialisten enteignet
drei von ihnen umgebracht im zweiten
weltkrieg wird das kaufhaus teilweise
zerstört und zu ddr zeiten gesprengt ich
finde das ding schön ich weiß nicht wie
es ihnen vergeht aber sie habe eine
bestimmte ästhetik dieser industrie
alice bus und so weiter rost ist
wunderbar und so weiter dieses patina
der geschichte das liebe ich
er hat damals die noch erhaltenen keller
des kaufhauses nach vielen jahren
dornröschenschlaf wieder entdeckt und
mit ihm den tresorraum dimitri hegemann
mit freunden sucht er nach dem mauerfall
nach neuen partyräumen im ostteil der
stadt zufällig stoßen sie dabei auf die
unterirdische ruine an der ehemaligen
deutsch deutschen grenze
dann hatten wir den kellerabgang
entdeckt hinter einem regal war bestand
also mit feuerzeug
also ich war so ergriffen alle an dich
weil du kannst in einen großen keller
komplex und in diesem komplex für den
weg in ein
diese strahlen kammer und das war
besonders in mir war auch sofort klar
dieser ort der hat das potenzial etwas
ganz großes auszurichten
und so kommt es auch der tresor wird zur
keimzelle der berliner technoszene und
lockt schnell raver aus aller welt an
heute sind die partys in der ehemaligen
stall kammer legendär auch wegen des
massiven trocken nebel einsatzes also
eigentlich was meistens so dass man
nicht mehr gesehen hat mit wem man da
jetzt gerade ist weil es wirklich
einfach völlig vernebelt war und ja das
sich einfach verlieren denn der musik
und das hat natürlich dann auch vom
optischen her wenn man nicht mehr weiß
wer steht vor einem kann es auch die
augen zumachen der tresor hat
musikgeschichte geschrieben
die tresortür erzählt 100 jahre berlin
geschichte
[Musik]